en france quand on perd c'est simple on
pose des questions gens dans la rue
prendre quand c'est quoi ton com bon
c'est quoi la france manque au parisien
[Applaudissements]
chute à la vache ouais
maintenant tu peux te fais pas maladroit
non mais les droits droit droit
ah la la
je te connais tous
à
[Applaudissements]
ça sert à rien de faire une chronique
[Rires]
d'après les frères dans la rue on pose
des questions aux gens tout ça et ils
répondent on s'est dit qu'est ce que
vous pensez des transformant parisien je
serai à paris pendant cinq semaines et
j'utilise toujours le métro et je pense
que le métro est fabuleuse et vite
non il ya enea pas des ravages aux frais
ils en pensent quoi fatiguer j'aime
beaucoup mais bob merci de toi it's
french teddy hockey avec mon frère on
connaît ba ba d'une au baba oui
magog la can a sonné la question à la
facilité et la rapidité
voilà c'est à 8 accessible et rapide
c'est tout oui aujourd'hui ça tombe bien
c'est un petit village on est anti
pollution donc lui de deux trains moins
cher pour les erreurs c'est pratique et
votre cheval en pense quoi
bonne question mais elle vit ici donc
pour elle c'est différent quoi accès à
chérie ça fait mine ont extrait
l'entêtant les chimistes fénelon on a
des bivouacs jan on n'était que tim cook
n'ont commencé
mike horn on est ric mike horn en
afrique a les mêmes ondes courtes après
mon nid s'interrompt plus parfait
mais moi aussi on voulait sont inadaptés
pour d'anaconda la quiche ou on va
dépouiller la tente on vous embrasse les
booth s'est toujours d'accumulation que
c'est un peu la catastrophe mois pour
les simples moi je pour aller travailler
je fais ma 20 minutes à pied tous les
jours et votre sale en pense quoi
votre soeur alors bon soin minceur
en fait c'est ma petite cousine voulpaix
saison nous visons futé c'est pas vrai
ah non non ah bon savrith est un ancien
candidat de ouf sur radio j
[Applaudissements]